واعلن مستشفى سوروكا الاسرائيلي في بئير
السبع انه استقبل الاربعاء 12 جنديا
اصيبوا في غزه حاله احدهم خطيره في حين
قال مستشفى هسه في القدس انه استقبل خلال
الساعات ال8 الماضيه ثمانيه جنود مصابين
نقلوا من ارض المعارك في غزه عبر مروحيات
عسكريه معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري وليد مع الاعلان الذي
بات يوميا عن القتلى والمصابين في صفوف
قوات الاحتلال هناك ايضا نمط جديد لربما
فيما يتعلق بان الاعلان لا ياتي فقط من
الجيش ولكن ايضا من
المستشفيات نعم المستشفيات اصبحت تعلن عن
الاصابات لانه في حتى قبل اكثر من اسبوع
لم يكن الاعلان عن الاصابات بين الجنود
والضباط في معارك قطاع غزه يتم الاعلان
عنه وكان يتحفظ عليه بامر من الرقابه
العسكريه والجيش لكن بعد ان قامت صحيفه
ارتس منذ شهر وبعد ان حصلت على قرار بذلك
وكشفت ان اعداد الاصابات عاليه جدا وانها
نحو 3000 ثم جاءت صحيفه يدعوت احرونوت
واعلنت بعد ذلك باسبوعين ان مجمل الاصابات
نحو 5000 واجبرت على ان تخفي رقم ال 5000
وتكت بالقول بان بينهم نحو 3000 اعترفت
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه بانهم اصيبوا
باعاقة مستشفى هداس في القدس الغربيه
ومستشفى سروك في بئر السبع وعندما ينقل
الجرحى الى مستشفيات في مناطق بعيده عن
قطاع غزه مثل القدس وتل ابيب معنى ذلك ان
المستشفيات القريبه من قطاع غزه سواء سروك
في بئر السبع او بارزيلاي في عسقلان انها
اصبحت مقتضى بالجرحى من الجنود اعداد
الجنود الذين يصابون بجراح باتت عاليه
ويوميا يتم الاعلان عن 20 الى اكثر من ذلك
الجيش ووزاره الدفاع وضعت موقعا على
صفحتها خاص بالتبليغ عن هذه الاعداد التي
تزداد بشكل يومي واليوم فجرا عندما اعلنوا
عن وقوع ثلاثه قتلى بينهم ضابطين في معارك
بجنوب قطاع غزه ووسط قطاع غزه في اشاره
الى ضراوه المعارك التي يشهدها تحديدا
مواقع مثل خان يونس وايضا حيي الدرج
والتفاح في مدينه غزه بشمال قطاع غزه
بالاعلان عن عن القتلى الثلاث يرتفع مجمل
قتلى الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدايه
ايه العمليه البريه في ال 26 من اكتوبر
الماضي الى 173 قتيلا ومجمل القتلى منذ
بدايه الحرب وطوفان الاقصى وال في هذه
الحرب التي دخلت يومها الث3 الى 501 هذه
اعداد يعتبرها الاسرائيليون عاليه جدا
لكنه يبدو ان رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو بات
ستند اليها في محاوله لعدم الخضوع لمطالب
ذوي الاسرائيليين الاسرى المحتجزين في
قطاع غزه الذين يحاولون الاستمرار في
احتجاجاتهم واليوم من المفترض ان تصل
مسيره شبابيه لسكان من غلاف غزه الى منطقه
القدس كانت قد انطلقت قبل ثلاثه اربعه
ايام من تل ابيب تطالب بوقف الحرب والدخول
فورا بابرام صفقه تبادل شامله ايه ليتم في
اطارها استعاده كافه الاسرى والمحتجزين
الاسرائليه في قطاع غزه حتى لو كانت في
مقابل الكل في مقا مقابل الكل بمعنى
الافراج عن جميع الاسرى الفلسطينيين في
السجون الاسرائيليه لكن نتنياهو لا يظهر
استعدادا بهذا الخصوص وتسلح بما وصفها
رساله من ذوي الجنود والضباط الذين قتلوا
في المعارك في قطاع غزه للقول بان ليس
لديه تفويض لوقف القتال وان التفويض
الوحيد لديه هو مواصله القتال هذا الموضوع
ايضا كان محورا في مجلس الحرب الليله
الماضيه والذي بحث ايضا مساله استمرار
الحرب والانتقال الى المرحله الثالثه لكن
نتنياهو يرفض السماح له ببحث ماذا سيكون
في اليوم التالي للحرب وهي مساله خلافيه
بينه وبين قيادات الجيش والامن وايضا مع
الولايات المتحده التي اوفد اليها مقربه
وزير الشؤون الاستراتيجيه دريمر للتمهيدي
لزياره بلينكن وزير الخارجيه الذي سيصل
الاسبوع المقبل في زياره ستكون الخامسه
منذ بدايه الحرب وعلى ذكر مجلس الحرب كان
هناك ايضا تصريحات لبين جانس لافته فيما
يتعلق بالتمزق الداخلي وتحذيره من استبدال
رؤوس الاذرع الامنيه في زمن الحرب ما
تفاصيل ما صرح به جانس وما الذي كان يرمي
اليه هذا جاء على خلفيه ان وزير ما يعرف
بالامن القومي اتمار بن كبر وهو متطرف من
حزب عظمه يهوديه مستوطن ومن تحالف
الصهيونيه الدينيه قرر عدم التمديد لمفوض
السجون لانه يتهمها بانها تقدم تسهيلات
للاسرى الفلسطيني وتحديدا للاسرى من حركه
حماس وهذا مخالف للاتفاق المبرم بين جانس
ونتنياهو والذي على اساسه اقيمت حكومه
الطوارئ والتي يراسها نتنياهو وانضم اليها
جانس مع بدايه هذه الحرب والذي يقضي بان
لا يتم لا عزل ولا تعيين ايا من اصحاب
الوظائف العليا في اداره البلاد وراى جانس
ان هذا مخالف لهذا الاتفاق وكان هناك
اجتماع ثلاثي يوم امس لكن بن كبير رفض
وهدد بانه سينسحب من الحكومه وهو ما اخاف
نتنياهو الذي حسب الاسرائيليين يعمل خدمه
لمصالحه الشخصيه وكيفيه تثبيت توليفته
اليمينيه المتطرفه ليبقى رئيسا للوزراء
حتى نهايه ولايته الى ما بعد اكثر من ثلا
سنوات على هذا الاساس جاء تصريح جانس لكن
في المقابل جانس لم يقرر الانسحاب من
حكومه نتنياهو الحاليه قبل
ان تضع الحرب اوزارها وهذا مؤشر اخر على
القضايا الخلافيه الداخليه في هذه الحكومه
كما ان هناك توتر بين نتنياهو وجانسل رفض
نتنياهو التعامل مع مطالب الجيش والامن
بخصوص ماذا سيجري في اليوم التالي لوقف
الحرب في قطاع غزه واضافه الى ذلك كله
جانس يشعر بان نتنياهو تقريبا يستخدمه
ويستخدم وجوده في الحكومه من اجل دحرجه
المسؤوليه على القيادات الامنيه والسياسيه
لانه يدرك جيدا ان تحقيقات سيتم فتحها وهو
ما اشار اليه ايضا مراقب الدوله نشكرك من
رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد العمري